- On this episode,
we talk about app launches,
we talk about health and
wellness professionals and
we talk about
fruit and vegetable stands?
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [DRock] Have you seen
the caption on Periscope?
- Let me see.
- [DRock] India and you write--
- And then it goes.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Yeah I saw that update
but I haven't played with it.
That's cool.
- [India] You draw
on it like Snapchat?
- Yeah so if I give her
a mustache like
I'm doing right now.
- [DRock] Yep. Yep.
That's cool.
Classic Gary.
(laughter)
206?
- [India] 206.
- [Tyler] You have 20 minutes.
- What's up everybody?
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this episode 206 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
India?
- [India] Sup?
- DRock on the 'scope.
Garrett Green in the house.
Tyler.
I mean this is a full house.
Just missing Uncle Jesse.
Feeling pretty good.
Feel ready.
It's funny.
I've got interesting
travel schedule tomorrow.
The 3 AM wake up call,
the 4 AM flight, right?
Really excited saw some
of the comments come
through on episode 205.
People felt that I was in good
form because I've been
out of the saddle.
I actually feel even
stronger for episode 206.
So India with that, I think we
should go classic route here.
- [India] Classic?
- Just classic.
We'll do our little show thing.
Oh, I still
haven't watched that.
- Oh my gosh.
- I want to watch
this right after this.
We're gonna do our little show
thing and then we're
just gonna ask questions.
I'm gonna give answers and
I'm gonna make an impact.
- Cool.
- Great.
You ready?
- I'm ready.
- Let's--
- get into
- [Both] the show.
- Very nice.
- [India] Alright, first one.
- By the way real quick
before we get into the show,
I'm trying to figure out
how to say this.
I've been thinking
about how to address this.
You guys are so sweet.
Let me make a very strong
statement, I'm always so humbled
and flattered and my ego is
scratched in such a good way
I'm always willing
to take a selfie.
So many of you, obviously with
the virality on Facebook and
stuff of that nature
I can feel the heat.
You see what's going on
when we're doing DailyVee.
So many of you are looking
at me and then tweeting
"I wish I stopped and said hi."
You can never bother me.
I'm so flattered.
I'm always ready to do it.
It's an
incredible accomplishment.
I feel incredible about it.
I feel like people lately have
eyeing me up and then tweeting
it and I see them and I knew
that they recognized me.
And I wish they stopped.
I would've loved to give some
daps, say thank you,
take a picture.
How about the other day?
When the guy's phone died.
You know about this?
You know about this.
- [Tyler] I was just talking--
- [Gary] DRock
told you about this?
Some guys phone
died when he came up.
I took it on mine
and emailed it to them.
Very sweet.
- [India] Yeah.
- I'm a sweet guy, India.
- [Voiceover] Mikkel asks, "Do
you ever pick and choose which
"clients you work with based on
how they do their business?"
- Yes. And no.
The answer is yes but
many times I don't.
I'm running a business.
And now, for example, we have
had big clients potentially come
through here which I thought
were in an industry that would
cause too much and very honestly
in a politically correct world,
in a world that we have
a lot of, I don't want
to call liberal thinkers.
There's absolutely things that
you have to do as a CEO that you
make decisions on who you do
business with based on what you
think is in the best
interest of your business.
For me it goes in
reverse in three orders.
What is the best
interest of everybody?
My responsibility'
to everybody here.
Which then is in essence
the logo and then
my feelings are third.
I've actually not taken on
business that I thought would
not be in the best interest of
the feelings and emotions and
thoughts and
strategies of my employees.
Though they may not have
100,000% aligned with me.
Let's say, I was 80 present
there but I felt like collective
was 100% there and
I take that responsibility.
I never judge based on how
they run their social media or
marketing because that's
what we're there to fix.
If that's where
Mikkel was going.
I don't blame companies you can
have one rogue CEO that makes
his wine company and bad
company but if she or he is fired
then they are a good company.
I also try to quantify that.
It's run through my mind.
I've absolutely made decisions.
Look, the people you surround
yourself with is an
indicator to who you are.
That is just the truth and
so my clients are a
representation of who I am.
But I have no problem having
alcoholic brands, sugar water.
These are not
things that scare me.
I'm not hypersensitive.
But if you make bombs, and
that's not a real life example,
or if you are the Patriots.
For example, I would never
take the Patriots as a client.
No shot.
Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Buddy asks,
"What's your advice for
"healthcare docs who want to
add value using social media to
"promote wellness and
attract ideal patients?"
- This is good.
I'm glad you
asked this question.
I actually think this is
something we need to challenge
ourselves on the show.
Oh, here's something that the
audience can do I don't know if
you guys heard that I
have a new search engine.
Both the questions and
answers, Staphon, pop it up.
Good.
Commercial time,
put it right here.
I want it. Okay.
It's unbelievable.
You have a lot of questions to
me, they've all been answered or
at least the ones on the show
and now they're very searchable.
If you are part of the Vayner
Nation, the Vayniacs out there
if you search something that
you got zero results for,
please tweet me and I'll start
passing it on to you.
I feel like I'm really happy you
asked this question because
it's getting to genres.
I think I want to go more
profession based in the 200s.
I want to do more
"I'm a contractor."
Please actually can we
all stand up and rise?
I haven't been doing this
consistently and I haven't
been asking you.
Please ask a more specific
question to your industry right
now use the hashtag #AskGaryVee,
throw that up here
Staphon as well.
A little editing for you.
Plus I love double checking
'cause I love when you forget
and I get mad.
That's a great question so that
question is based I want to make
sure I get that one little piece
because I went on a tangent.
- [India] Advice for
healthcare's doctors that want
to add value using social media
to promote wellness and attract
ideal patients.
- I think you go long tail.
What's the name?
- His name is Buddy.
- Buddy, I think it's really
important thing to actually go
long tail and I think one of the
biggest things that I mean by
that lawyers, real estate
agents, insurance brokers,
wine guys, perfect timing.
The reason this popped, this
old show that I used to do
the reason it popped was
'cause I was really
giving my best advice.
And I didn't care if you came to
Wine Library and bought this or
you bought it somewhere else,
I was trying to
provide you value.
As long as you care more about
the first part of your question
than the second part of
the question, you will win.
As long as you want to
provide more value
than you want
customers you will win.
So long as that's 51 and the
second part of your
question's 49, you will win.
So what does that mean?
That means that you put out on
video things might actually
solve people's complete problems
with them not ever coming into
your ecosystem and
becoming a client.
Some people in marketing, so
many people in information and
services want to give you a
little taste so that you then
come into their full circle.
I have been very successful in
going the other route which is
giving so much and then using
that equity, that guilt,
that word-of-mouth to be
the gateway to business.
I would tell you, Buddy, that
you need to put out the best
advice and content that you can.
That your videos and pictures
and audio and written words need
to be, here's a scenario here's
exactly what you should do.
And that might be remedied
over-the-counter, that might be
remedied with some old
Western point of view.
That might be remedied by
somebody going to a clinic or a
place that has nothing to do
with you and you have to be
okay with that.
If you are not okay with
that, all of your actions
A.K.A. all of your content will
feel that way to all the end
consumers and then they will
feel that it is transactional or
that is actually a gateway.
So many of you watch the
show because I think you deeply
inherently, whether you
understand it or not, realize
I'm trying to put out the
best content that I can here.
There is no ", something."
There is no this ends or in the
middle of it I'm trying to sign
you up for my
school or this and that.
Yes, every three years, and we
just went through it, or two
years you'll hear from me
buy my book, buy my book.
I don't know if you guys have
noticed I've even been less on
bookselling the last 45
days than I expected.
I've been zero.
I think I did
something the other day.
One.
I think your actions
speak louder than your words.
So one more time I want to hear
the way the question is framed.
- [India] Advice for health care
doctors that want to add value
using social media.
- Stop for a second.
Do that.
I don't give you advice.
Here's the advice: make
pictures, videos, written words
and audio pieces of
content that bring people value.
If you're a good
health professional,
you'll know what to do.
'Cause I really understand
wine I knew what to do.
The ","-part needs to be the
trust that back content is
actually going to bring you
what you actually want to happen
which was the second
part of the question.
You're not watching The
#AskGaryVee Show because you
don't care about the
business ramification.
This is a business show.
Right?
It just happens to be a business
show that is doing business in a
higher manner than
the rest of the market.
How are they feeling
about it on the 'scope?
- [DRock] They like it.
- Do they know that
you're holding it?
- [DRock] Yep.
- [Gary] Did they know
the famous DRock is "you're
unbelievable, you should be
making movies" skills are
holding this?
He's fancy.
You too, you too.
(laughter)
You too, you two
are super fancy.
- What no I've never
been on a jet.
- This is true.
DRock is very fancy but India
you get stopped everywhere.
- [DRock] Yep.
- [Gary] You take selfies.
We haven't been doing
#AskGaryVee and DailyVee's been
taking over so DRock has clearly
closed the gap on the fame race
but you know what?
Staphon, have Zak make
a little chart for me.
I want a real good
design here right now.
Put it right here.
I want a fame graph with India's
face and DRock and I think we
should bring it up once every
eight or nine shows and see
who's winning in the fame.
- [India] DRock
follows you everywhere.
- Oh but that might be
because he's hustling harder.
- [India] Maybe.
- [Tyler] You get
the engagement.
- [India] True.
But I don't think my, I think
that your brand translates
better to his brand.
I feel like the
crossover is way bigger.
- What about when I last saw
you in the wild on Snapchat.
- [India] Yeah.
(laughter)
Surprising I watch
your Snapchat.
- Alright, let's move it.
- [Voiceover] Patrick asks,
"What did you learn selling
"baseball cards that I could
apply to selling vegetables at
"my first farmers
market coming up?"
- Patrick, this is amazing.
Watch their eyes.
That's what I
learned in baseball cards.
As you guys now know or if
you don't know if you go to my
website right now link it.
You got a lot of work to do.
This is gonna
come out next week.
I day trade attention
and build businesses.
When you day trade attention,
eyes and ears are
very important.
What I learned and this is by
the way this is a scenario,
I would literally be at a
baseball card show and
I'm going to paint it for you
'cause it's really important.
I would get there at 6, 7 AM.
The show would open at 9, 7, 8
AM and I would have my table and
I would sit there for hours,
Garrett pay attention, and
I would sit there for hours and
I would do this and then this and
then this and I would look
and I would come around.
I'll never for get this,
I'd always come around.
I try to understand it
from their perspective.
I would pay attention to what
the other dealers were doing.
And so I'd be like, "Okay, he
has a lot of boxes here so if
"I go white space here,"
I gave a lot, I'm a kid.
I'm 13 and 14.
And I'm thinking about how would
you walk through this mall and
if you just saw that guy's table,
what does my table
have to do so that.
You know, there's
80 tables here.
What would you have to see there
that would then make this stand
out in the context
of that and that.
And then what could I do.
If you look at his table, this
is a big punchline,
the orange thing.
So let the
Ken Griffey Jr. rookie card.
Do I put in the middle?
But then it's hidden
by all the other cards.
Do I put it top left corner?
It's funny, even as a kid
as this is how I understand
websites, I understood that's
how people read so I would put
my flashiest, hardest core,
hottest items in the top left
corner because I understood
that's how the I would look at
it and be like whoa
there stuff here.
To me, that is a really
interesting insight
to how I roll.
It how I think about the first
five seconds of the video
when you watch it.
It's how I think
about my tweets.
It's how I think about my
opening line when I give a
keynote speech that all of you
have seen and the cliché how
many people know who
don't know who I am?
Everybody raises their hands.
Oh shit that hurts.
Ha-ha-ha humility.
Because I'm about to
deploy a lot of ego.
You know, for all my "yeah" I'm
quite calculated and that's how
thought about it.
What I tell you, Patrick is it?
Patrick, pay attention to the eyes.
Understand the context think
about the parking lot flow of
the vegetable market and think
about what most people walk
through and how do you have it?
Do you have a vegetable
that nobody else has?
Do you have a better price on
something that nobody else has?
Understand what they just saw.
Understand where they're going.
Where's the bathroom
and port-o-potties.
Where's the honey lady?
There's the sausage guy.
I'm the only person that sells
pickles in this entire row.
Think, think, think and then
when you sit down and watch
in your first table just watch.
That's all I did.
I looked like a weird dude
probably because
I would just watch.
And I would watch
like a god damn hawk.
And I would just watch and
see their eyes and then adjust.
Maybe that wasn't working.
Counterpunching their attention.
That was cool, right?
You like that the whole?
That was neat, right?
You like because that was
I tend to be very clouds
but that was very dirt.
I don't go dirt a lot.
I try to dirt for you guys but
clouds is how I win but I got a
lot more dirt in
me than you think.
(India inaudible)
That's why I think the industry
specific questions are good too.
Good observation, India.
(rising pitch noise)
(laughter)
That was the graph of fame.
Good job to stay along.
- [Garrett] I was chuckling
looking at the
Jab, Jab, Jab Right Hook because
it's essentially your content
standing in front of it just
like your table.
- That's right.
- [India and Gary] That's true.
- [Voiceover] Apple Pie Parties
asks, "How do you know if you
"should continue to bootstrap
or bite the bullet and
"accept investor funding?"
- APP this is a tough
question for everybody.
Every situation is different.
This is why I struggle with dirt
because the truth is I can't
give you an answer without
really knowing your business
and knowing you.
Everyone of you that's sitting
there deciding between and do
I take on investment or do
I continue to bootstrap has so
many other variables:
Where are you in your
personal relationship?
How sick and tired are
you of bootstrapping?
How big of a
business do you have?
Way too many of you are taking
on investment when your business
can only be worth $3 to $5
million and then you're giving
up such a big percentage and
your patience over 3 to 5 years
would have made you
a lot more money.
Then you getting a percentage of
the only 3 to 5 million top line
revenue business that you have.
The truth is, India, that every
business has it's own variables.
What I will tell you is that I
think money will get tight soon.
Think we've been living through
a fairly good times even though
most people don't realize that.
Especially in start up culture
though the mass economics in
America are okay, the startup
culture, the people that are
building business in the
environment that would watch a
show like this have
had it pretty good.
And I think that
will dry up shortly.
And so I think that
if you need the money
you should go and
get it immediately.
If you don't need the money and
it's more about do I accelerate
or do I keep grinding,
I think that comes down to the
individual and their
situations at home, life,
their level of patience,
how much they enjoy the process.
I kind of alluded to almost
sabotaging myself on DailyVee
the other day 'cause I
love the process so much.
So I hold off on gratification.
- [Voiceover] Devon asks, "How
crucial do you think is an app's
"launch is? Product Hunt?"
- That's a really good question.
Again, a layered question.
Ultimately, I think if you make
a great product the answer is
not that much.
Snapchat's launch
was nonexistent.
There's no frickin'
Snapchat launch party.
There was no big to do.
Instagram 'cause Systrom was
in the ecosystem he did get the
Kevin Rose's and the Ferriss'
and things of that nature but
that was just a small
pie because the
tech space is so small.
I would argue stunningly little.
I think we've seen a ton of
people have the big party,
the big hype.
We're gonna do it.
Look at Title even with
its recent success with
some exclusives.
I'm not bullish on
that in the long-term.
They had Madonna and
Hove and everybody's there.
I think way too many people
over promise and under deliver.
I think way too many people try
to sell on the sizzle and
not the steak.
And I would say net-net
if we look at, you know,
Uber I was there.
There was no big launch.
Just worked right away.
I think we look at
the top 150 apps.
Musically, what was the
launch of Musically? Right?
I would actually argue that most
of the apps that are successful
didn't have some big launch.
Early momentum is good but
we've seen early momentum
fade very quickly.
I think your thesis of
your business has to matter.
I think at the end of the
day this is absolutely
tortoise and hare.
And I think the
turtle and every time.
I think it has a lot to do
with ego and it feels really
good in that first year.
You're a founder,
you're cool, you're hot.
You might be on the cover of a
magazine and being featured on
TechCrunch but I just don't
think it's how you start,
I think it's how you finish.
And very honestly, I would tell
you that most of my confidence
and most of this "it" thing that
you guys feel and most of this
swag or whatever the hell you
want to call it comes from me
knowing what's going to
happen when I'm 70,
not what's happening right now.
I feel like I'm going to be 70
and watch this moment one day
and I'm gonna be like,
"Man, I was so young.
"I had so much in front I
thought it was old at 40
but I was so young."
Good show. Yes.
- [Tyler] DVB
canceled for tonight.
- What are you doing, right now?
I'm still in the show.
(laughter)
Tyler with a rookie mistake.
I don't know how you and AJ
rolled but I am still in
show mode here, Ty.
Question of the day,
what's the biggest mistake
that you made recently?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
What's up guys?
Hope you enjoyed the show.
Please do I get to
link it up anywhere?
Is it in here or
is it down below?
Is it in print or in my video?
- [Staphon] It'll be
down to your left.
- It's here down to my left.
Right here, there's a button
for them to subscribe
to my YouTube video?
Yeah it's that
little buggy thing.
That's right guys, click this.
That's right, use that.